un tercer confinamiento entra en vigor
este sábado a la medianoche en toda
francia pero quienes tengan que
movilizarse por fuerza mayor tendrán
plazo hasta el martes cuando nadie podrá
moverse a más de 10 kilómetros de
distancia de su residencia las nuevas
restricciones anunciadas por el
presidente de manuel mckeon incluyen el
cierre de escuelas y negocios no
esenciales durante tres semanas
soy madre soltera así que si será un
cambio por supuesto que cambiarán las
cosas voy a tener que lidiar con la
primera semana de aprendizaje a
distancia desde casa y las dos semanas
siguientes serán vacaciones en casa les
va a costar el mismo en italia la nueva
curva epidemiológica durante el último
mes obligó al gobierno de endurecer las
restricciones durante esta semana santa
el país permanecerá cerrado y nadie
podrá salir de casa salvo por una
emergencia o trabajo el viernes por la
noche el papá francisco encabezó una
procesión del vía crucis en una basílica
de san pedro' casi vacía mientras tanto
españa pero luego hasta el 16 de abril
los controles en la frontera terrestre
con portugal y hasta el 19 la 40 en
obligatoria para pasajeros
de brasil perú colombia y 9 países
africanos y en alemania la canciller
angela merkel pidió celebrar la semana
santa en pequeños grupos
del wii debería ser una semana santa
tranquila con los más cercanos a usted
con un contacto muy reducido le insto a
que se abstenga de todo viaje no
esencial y que en consecuencia cumplamos
todas las reglas
las nuevas restricciones en el
continente permanecerán en estas
celebraciones mientras europa mira con
preocupación la evolución de los datos
de la pandemia la ocupación en los
hospitales y un plan de vacunación que
avanza lentamente